26 million people confined to their
homes and no end in sight
following a public uproar shanghai
officials have now allowed parents to
stay with children infected with kovitt
19 but the full lockdown which started
in parts of china's largest city 10 days
ago has been extended
images almost identical to the beginning
of the pandemic two years ago
shanghai's residents have been ordered
to stay at home only supermarkets and
pharmacies are still open
for this fish processing factory the
financial toll is catastrophic according
to its supply records fish was delivered
and processed on march 22nd since then
production lines have stood still
two weeks ago revenue was just fifty
thousand yuan which wasn't even enough
to pay my staff
from fifty thousand yuan about seven
thousand five 500 euros that turnover is
now zero a state-owned bank has issued
the factory a low-interest loan worth
450 000 euros its manager hopes it will
be enough to keep the company afloat
during the lockdown so i had no access
to cash because of the outbreak and then
suddenly this loan provides a lifeline
no one knows how long the lockdown will
last even with very low case numbers
chinese authorities impose curfews mass
testing and seal of entire cities the
case now in shanghai
state media is reporting that these
measures could reduce new infections to
zero within two weeks
this is also the hope of the owners of
shuttered companies and stores who all
fear for their businesses
let's get more on this from dw soltsung
han in taipei so 26 million people on
lockdown
how are they reacting
people's frustration is growing and it's
shocking to see residents of different
buildings chanting slogans like live
this restriction or give us food or we
will die from hunger we also see small
rioters trying to rush out to get health
care food and other life necessities
many more people took to chinese social
media to share their stories in some
extreme cases threats or self-harm or
violence were reported it's really tough
for the government to handle because not
just the general public but the medical
staff police officers middle level or
senior officials are disgusted by the
total lockdown people just cannot stand
it anymore
and so with an entire city population
confined to their homes does this mean
nobody is out working
yes and no no one is out but people are
still working in fact before the total
lockdown from march 30th
employees of many firms already set up
tents in their offices or they were put
into food and housing in the factory
mode with blank with bunk beds in the
factory and showers in the toilets after
the total lockdown the government sent
drones to warn anyone who leaves any
building so for most industries working
from home is an option or they have to
implement closed loop production with
employees living working and traveling
only between two points within the
factory area so they are not out but
working
so let's try to look at the bigger
picture here um economists are
predicting this lockdown will cost
shanghai
more than three and a half percentage
points in economic growth this year what
is it likely to mean for china's economy
as a whole
shanghai is the largest and most popular
city in china it contributes the most to
its gdp along with beijing guangzhou and
zinzen there are reports saying that if
shanghai is closed for two weeks the
impact on china's gdp for that month
would be about two percent if it is
closed for one month then loss is
roughly four percent china is likely to
struggle reaching its growth target of
5.5 this year it will seriously
undermine the confidence of foreign
investors and discourage many potential
investors and many foreign companies in
shanghai will have to consider the risk
of repeated disruptions or restrictions
in the logistics supply chain and choose
to downsize or even relocate
and with the economic toll of its zero
covert strategy mounting is china likely
to stick to this policy
yes
one reason commentary piece on the
official newspaper explains the logic
behind it china's zero kovis strategy
compared with the idea of coexisting
with the virus is on the surface a
battle of ideas strategies but in
essence it is a battle of systems
national power governance capacity and
even civilization to the beijing
authority the statement shows that the
chinese communist party leadership sees
health prevention and epidemic
prevention as a battle with the west
chinese president xi jinping wants to
use it as a tool to realize his personal
achievement at all at all cost
dw correspondent so sung han in taipei
so thank you
you